Sind Sie zufrieden mit der Zeit?
Es geht.
Ich musste meine Ansprüche,
was Zeiten angeht, zurückschrauben -
notwendigerweise.
Die Diagnose Krebs war ein Schock.
Nicht nur für Frank Urbaniok, sondern
auch für seinen Sohn und seine Frau.
Go, Frank!
Urbaniok war 25 Jahre lang
der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
Gerichtspsychiater der Schweiz.
Jetzt ist er
aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
von all seinen Ämtern zurückgetreten.
Damit endet eine Ära.
Wer die Ära Urbaniok verstehen will,
der muss zurück ins Jahr 1993.
Am Nachmittag des 30. Oktobers 1993
wurde in Zollikerberg
die 20-jährige Pfadiführerin Pasquale
Brumann vergewaltigt und ermordet.
Der Täter war kein Unbekannter.
Erich Hauert
hatte bereits zwei Sexualmorde
und elf Vergewaltigungen begangen.
Man hat es hier eindeutig
mit der Art Täter zu tun,
der extrem gefährlich
und langfristig - lebenslang -
unbehandelbar ist.
Es zeigt sich
eine solch massive Brutalität
und eine Penetranz der Gewalt
und der ... Tendenz -
wir nennen das chronifizierte
Vergewaltigungsdisposition -
zusammen
mit der Bereitschaft zu töten.
Das ist tief
in der Persönlichkeit verwurzelt,
hat zu ganz vielen Delikten geführt.
Das ist dann so stark
in der Persönlichkeit verankert,
dass es da nicht um Therapie geht,
sondern darum,
die Bevölkerung langfristig
vor diesen Tätern zu schützen.
Der Fall
löste Betroffenheit und Wut aus.
Wieso wurden einem solchen Menschen
unbegleitete Hafturlaube bewilligt?
Wieso konnte er weitermorden?
Der Justizvollzug war
in seinen Grundfesten erschüttert.
Die Verantwortlichen erklärten
den unbegleiteten Hafturlaub damit,
dass sie Hauert
mit Vollzugslockerungen
auf die Freiheit vorbereiten wollten.
Denn: Trotz
lebenslänglicher Freiheitsstrafe
hätten sie ihn bald entlassen müssen.
Ich muss Ihnen aber sagen:
In den letzten 30 Jahren,
die ich übersehe -
und Strafrechtler
konnten mir keinen Fall nennen -
war nie ein lebenslänglicher Täter
wirklich lebenslänglich bei uns.
Nach 15-16 Jahren
wurden sie alle entlassen.
Es sind die unabhängigen Gerichte,
die ein solches Urteil fällen.
In diesem Fall hat die Justizbehörde
eine Verwahrung beantragt.
Der Staatsanwalt
beantragte eine Verwahrung.
Und das Gericht
hat die mildere Massnahme genommen,
nämlich
die lebenslängliche Freiheitsstrafe.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Urbaniok kam zwei Jahre
nach diesem Mord in die Schweiz
und stellte schnell fest, dass
diese Erklärungen irreführend waren.
... nur im Gefängnis therapiert.
Zum einen muss man sagen:
Es gab keinen Hinderungsgrund,
lebenslange Gefängnisstrafen
auch lebenslang zu vollziehen.
Das wäre rechtlich
auch damals möglich gewesen.
Die Praxis war halt anders.
Zum Zweiten führten die Verwahrung-
en, die damals ausgesprochen wurden,
dazu, dass die Täter generell nach
drei, vier Jahren entlassen wurden.
Das führte z.T.
zur paradoxen Reaktion der Gerichte.
Die Gerichte
sagten dann aufgrund der Praxis:
"Bevor der gefährliche Täter nach
drei, vier Jahren wieder rauskommt,
beantragen wir lieber
eine endliche Freiheitsstrafe
von fünf, zehn, 12 Jahren -
dann ist er länger drin."
Was natürlich das Problem nur
zeitlich nach hinten verschob.
Diese Analyse,
wenn man sie so bezeichnen will,
ist von mir aus gesehen ... falsch
und deckt die wirklichen Probleme
eher zu als auf.
Opfer wurden lange
als unvermeidliche Kollateralschäden
einer humanen Justiz gesehen,
Straftaten als gesellschaftliches
Phänomen begriffen,
nicht als individuelle Problematik.
Es galt, die sozialen Verhältnisse
zu verändern,
dann fänden Täter quasi von alleine
zurück auf den rechten Weg.
Der ganze Strafvollzug war
auf Resozialisierung ausgerichtet.
Dass es Menschen gibt,
vor denen man die Gesellschaft
dauerhaft schützen muss,
war damals undenkbar.
Guten Abend,
liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer.
Mich würde interessieren,
Frank Urbaniok ...
Neue Rezepte waren gefragt.
Der gut 30-jährige Urbaniok
übernahm die Themenführerschaft.
Die Justiz
müsse potenzielle Opfer schützen,
dafür brauche es
den Mut zu harten Entscheidungen.
Bei diesen Tätern
geht es nicht um Behandlung,
um das Rückfallrisiko zu senken.
Das zu tun wäre therapeutischer
Grössenwahn und gefährlich.
Es geht darum, das klar zu erkennen,
zu deklarieren und zu vollziehen,
auch lebenslang.
Wir machen das
nach humanitären Gesichtspunkten.
Die Sicherheit der Bevölkerung
geht vor.
Er erkannte, dass sich via Medien
die öffentliche Meinung
und politische Prozesse
beeinflussen lassen.
Frank Urbaniok ist
Gerichtspsychiater im Kanton Zürich.
Wir fragten den renommierten
Gerichtspsychiater Frank Urbaniok.
Das möchte ich mit dem bekanntesten
Psychiater der Schweiz diskutieren,
Frank Urbaniok.
Frank Urbaniok, Professor
für forensische Psychiatrie.
Er unterstützt mit seiner Arbeit
Justiz und Polizei.
Er ist ein Mensch, der polarisiert.
Er ist charismatisch, innovativ ...
Er kann zuweilen
etwas von einem Pfau haben.
Wo viel Licht ist,
ist auch Schatten. Das ist so.
Schwer zu verstehen, was in einem
solchen Menschen vor sich geht.
Wir versuchen es mit dem erfahrenen
Gerichtspsychiater Frank Urbaniok.
Guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
Frank Urbaniok war gefragt -
nicht nur bei den Medien,
sondern auch
als Gutachter vor Gericht.
Herr Urbaniok war in der Schweiz
sicher eine wahnsinnig
massgebliche Person.
Bis er von einem Tag auf den anderen
aus der Öffentlichkeit verschwand.
* Dumpfe, elektronische Klänge *
Während seiner Erkrankung
war Medienprofi Urbaniok
nicht erreichbar für Journalisten.
Es existieren keine Bilder
aus dieser schwierigen Zeit.
Weil das für mich so persönliche
und ernste Situationen sind.
Ich fände es fast etwas makaber,
wenn live eine Kamera für
die Öffentlichkeit mitlaufen würde.
Und ähm ...
Ein wenig
ist es vielleicht auch Aberglaube,
dass ich das Schicksal
nicht herausfordern möchte.
Seit rund zwei Jahren ist er
in Behandlung am Zürcher Unispital.
In regelmässigen Abständen
muss er sich hier untersuchen lassen
und dann
jeweils auf die Ergebnisse warten.
Es ist eine Situation,
die ja sehr viele Menschen kennen.
Da bin ich nichts Besonderes.
Ich glaube, mir geht es auch gleich
wie vielen anderen.
Immer drei bis vier Tage
vor der Untersuchung
verlangsamt sich das Leben
wie in Zeitlupe.
Mir gelingt es immer schlecht,
mich vom Termin abzulenken.
Der rückt dann immer mehr
ins Zentrum meines Denkens.
Es ist natürlich
letztlich eine Situation,
der ich ausgeliefert bin.
Ich kann selber nichts machen.
Ich bin in einer Warteposition,
warte auf die Untersuchung
und das Ergebnis.
Das ist mit erheblichem
psychischem Druck verbunden.
Es ist auch eine Einengung
des Lebens in diesen Momenten.
Aber ... Am Ende muss man sagen:
Auch solche Situationen
gehören zum Leben.
Er hat Bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs.
Ich kann mich gut daran erinnern.
Ich habe an einem Freitag ein
Computertomogramm, ein CT, gemacht.
Der Arzt zeigte mir dann den Befund.
Ich wusste sofort, was es bedeutet:
dass es nicht gut aussieht,
dass es schwierig und hässlich wird.
Urbaniok hatte eine statistische
Überlebenschance von weniger als 5 %.
Inzwischen
ist seine Perspektive besser,
aber die Gefahr eines Rückfalls
bleibt erheblich.
Die Abstände werden grösser, aber
wir sehen uns trotzdem ab und zu.
Wir sagten sechs Monate. Im Juni
ist der nächste Termin. - Genau.
Und zwischendrin noch mal ein MRI.
Es stimmt ziemlich genau, zu sagen:
Was ich früher an einem Tag machte,
verteilt sich jetzt auf eine Woche.
Und es gibt auch Tage,
an denen ich gar nichts mache.
Urbaniok
bezieht eine Invaliditätsrente.
Er braucht jeden Tag
längere Ruhephasen
und ist darum
nur noch in einem kleinen Pensum
als selbständiger Gutachter
und Supervisor tätig.
Vor seiner Erkrankung
bestand sein Leben v.a. aus Arbeit.
65-Std.-Wochen waren normal.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass ich etwas bewegt habe.
Mir ist sehr bewusst, dass alles,
was wir als Menschen bewegen,
immer bestenfalls ein Tropfen
auf den heissen Stein ist.
Sie haben den Strafvollzug der
Schweiz doch massgeblich verändert.
Ich glaube, in der Tat
einige Akzente gesetzt zu haben.
Wie viel davon bleibt,
wie viel in einer Perspektive
von bis zu 40 Jahren noch da ist ...
Ich glaube, da ist ...
... immer
viel Bescheidenheit angesagt.
Urbaniok hat sich viele Freunde,
aber auch viele Feinde gemacht.
Er gilt als Hardliner,
ja als Wegsperrer der Nation.
Thomas Manhart leitet
das Zürcher Amt für Justizvollzug
und war Urbanioks Chef.
Er hat ihn differenziert erlebt,
nicht als pauschalen Wegsperrer.
Ich denke, mit diesem Label wird
man ihm überhaupt nicht gerecht.
Ich habe mit ihm wohl öfters
über Fälle
debattiert bis gestritten,
in denen er sagte, dass sich
eine Lockerung vertreten lässt,
und zwar auch bei wirklich ...
... extrem schlimmen Fällen -
natürlich nach Jahr und Tag,
zehn, 15 Jahren.
Da hatte ich
manchmal stärkere Bedenken als er
und ordnete
z.B. ein zweites Obergutachten an.
Seit dem Fall Hauert
sanken die Rückfallraten markant.
Es gilt:
im Zweifel für die Sicherheit.
* Ruhige Elektroklänge *
Von hier kommt Urbaniok:
aus dem Rheinland.
Geboren ist er in Köln,
aufgewachsen in Düsseldorf.
Er studierte in Münster Medizin
und wurde Assistenzarzt
an der psychiatrischen Landesklinik
Langenfeld.
Dorthin wollen wir,
aber Urbaniok hat sich verfahren.
(Elektronische Frauenstimme)
Bitte 100 m der Strasse folgen.
Sein schlechter Orientierungssinn
ist legendär.
Auch Wege, die er jahrelang gefahren
ist, erkennt er nicht wieder.
Ein skurriles Detail
angesichts seiner sonstigen Brillanz.
Dank Navigationsgerät sind wir
doch noch in Langenfeld angekommen.
Zunächst arbeitete er hier mit
Suchtkranken, dann mit Schizophrenen.
Er landete schliesslich
in der forensischen Psychiatrie,
weil ihm angeboten wurde,
eine Station zu übernehmen
und völlig neu zu konzipieren.
Diese Herausforderung reizte ihn,
weniger die Forensik an sich.
So sah es damals nicht aus.
1994 öffnete er erstmals
einem Fernsehteam seine Türen.
(Originalkommentar) Es ist
die psychiatrische Landesklinik
in Langenfeld im Rheinland,
die seit anderthalb Jahren
neue Ideen für die Therapie
von Sexualstraftätern entwickelt.
Wer hier lebt,
hat schwere Verbrechen begangen.
Doch mit Knast hat es nichts zu tun,
wir lassen uns aufklären.
Alle Patienten
haben eine Persönlichkeitsstörung,
die ihre Taten
wesentlich beeinflusste.
Psychiater Frank Urbaniok
will mit seiner Methode
zu den Wurzeln der Störung.
und die Therapien
wurden hochintensiv.
(Originalton)
Ein Pfleger spielt den Vater
und der ehemals
brutale Sexualstraftäter
fühlt wie ein kleiner Junge -
Videoaufnahmen aus der Klinik.
Urbaniok erkannte das Potenzial von
Therapien, aber auch deren Grenzen.
Klar, es gibt Menschen,
die besser ein Leben lang
weggeschlossen werden,
weil das Risiko
nicht vertretbar ist.
Das waren neue Töne
in der forensischen Psychiatrie.
Ich wurde für diese Position
z.T. sehr stark angegriffen
bis hin zu beschimpft.
Man warf mir vor, es sei eine
inhumane und unethische Position.
Es gab z.T. harsche,
wütende Reaktionen.
Ich habe das
aus einer Erfahrung gesagt,
Nicht aus der Theorie,
vom Schreibtisch aus,
sondern aus konkreter Arbeit.
Damals war das
aber eine Exotenposition.
Liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer,
herzlich willkommen zur "Arena".
Unser Thema: Kindsmissbrauch -
wie hart muss man Täter strafen
und wie gut kann man Opfer schützen?
In der Schweiz
herrschte damals Ratlosigkeit.
Klar war nur, dass sich
Grundsätzliches ändern musste,
um Erfahrungen der Eltern
eines missbrauchten Kindes
künftig zu verhindern.
Welche Entscheidung des Gerichts
hätten Sie denn erwartet?
Schon, dass er eingesperrt wird.
Eine unbedingte Strafe
wäre auf jeden Fall nötig gewesen.
Wie hat das Gericht
den Entscheid begründet?
Im groben Entscheid,
den wir schon bekamen, steht:
Es sei ein sehr
rücksichtsvoller Täter gewesen.
* Raunen *
Er habe die Kleine
an den Ausgangspunkt zurückgebracht.
Der zweite Punkt war:
Der Monat Untersuchungshaft
habe ihm so zugesetzt,
dass man mit Sicherheit sagen könne,
dass er nichts mehr mache.
* Raunen *
Das haben wir schon schriftlich.
Urbaniok sah seine Mission:
Die Mehrheit der Täter
professionell therapieren,
um ihre Risiken zu senken,
und die Unbehandelbaren wegsperren -
wenn nötig für immer.
Dieses Thema wird auch
in den nächsten Wochen beschäftigen.
Die Verwahrungs-Initiative
wurde überraschend angenommen.
Die Annahme
der Verwahrungs-Initiative
gab Urbaniok und seiner Mission
Rückenwind.
Im Gegensatz zu fast allen anderen
forensischen Psychiatern
traut er sich zu,
Tätern eine dauerhafte
Untherapierbarkeit zu attestieren.
Wir reden über eine kleine Gruppe.
Da kann man mit grosser
Zuverlässigkeit feststellen:
Da sind die Risiken so extrem hoch
und die Erfolgsaussichten
so extrem gering,
dass jede Grenze der Abwägbarkeit
überschritten ist,
dass die lebenslange Sicherung
im Vordergrund steht.
Für eine extrem kleine Gruppe
ist das zuverlässig möglich.
Mit der Umsetzung dieser Initiative
tut sich die Justiz schwer.
Aber sie befeuerte einen Paradigmen-
wechsel, den Urbaniok prägte.
Täter sollen nicht mehr nur für
begangenes Unrecht bestraft werden.
Auch potenzielle Risiken
sollen erkannt
und wenn möglich
wegtherapiert werden.
Und die Justiz sperrt präventiv weg.
Wer hochgefährlich und untherapierbar
ist, entscheiden Gerichte -
gestützt
auf psychiatrische Gutachten.
Strafrechtler Marcel Niggli
gehört zu den schärfsten Kritikern
dieser Entwicklung
vom Schuld- zum Präventionsprinzip.
Das bewirkt aus meiner Sicht
relativ deutlich,
dass für einen Straftäter
der eigentlich gefährliche Mensch
im Strafverfahren
nicht der Staatsanwalt sondern
der forensische Psychiater ist.
Das ist der gefährlichste Mensch -
was immer der sagt,
hat oben keine Grenze.
Und es ist nicht überprüfbar.
Es ist ein Mensch,
der über ihre Zukunft entscheidet,
ohne dafür Verantwortung
übernehmen zu müssen.
Je mehr Sicherheit man wünscht,
desto mehr
installiert man solche Strukturen.
Man vergisst dabei,
dass sie jemand zahlt.
Nicht finanziell, sondern:
Wer trägt das Risiko eines Fehlers?
Wenn die Bevölkerung
kein Risiko tragen will,
dass jemand zu Unrecht rauskommt -
aber wer trägt das Risiko,
wenn er zu Unrecht reinkommt?
Das Pendel ist ganz sicher
in die andere Richtung geschwungen,
man ist sehr
für Risiken sensibilisiert.
Ich glaube auch, dass das System
an einigen Stellen überdreht.
Das ist ganz sicher so.
Da kann man schon
Entwicklungen beobachten,
wo durch bürokratische Prozesse,
immer mehr Abläufe
und Kompliziertheiten
die Entscheidwege
so lang und kompliziert werden,
dass der eine oder andere
Das ist genauso zu kritisieren und
rechtsstaatlich genauso bedenklich,
wie wenn auf der anderen Seite
Fehler passieren.
Urbaniok
will mit Therapien und Prognosen
jedem Einzelfall gerecht werden.
Das könne sein Fach.
Das Problem sei,
dass dieses Potenzial
oft nicht ausgeschöpft werde.
Darum hat er FOTRES entwickelt:
ein System für Risikoeinschätzungen
und zur Qualitätssicherung.
Urbaniok arbeitet als selbständiger
Gutachter und Supervisor,
soweit es seine Gesundheit zulässt.
In diesem Fall
geht es um einen Pädosexuellen,
bei dem unklar ist,
wie es weitergehen soll.
Verwahren oder weitertherapieren?
Zwei Gutachterinnen, die bisher
nichts mit dem Fall zu tun hatten,
sollen eine Empfehlung abgeben.
Sie haben Urbaniok beigezogen.
Was ist seine Motivation
in der Therapie?
Was will er erreichen?
Was sind seine Erfahrungen?
Was ist seine Perspektive?
Was sagt er dazu? Sagt er was?
Er möchte arbeiten können,
wirklich körperliche Arbeit.
Aber auch nicht etwas Stupides,
weil er auch etwas für den Kopf
braucht, das ihn ablenkt.
Er möchte aber nicht
in eine Einrichtung
nur für erwachsene Sexualstraftäter.
Er möchte am Schluss aber auch
in ein enges Setting,
möglichst geschlossen, wo er
keinen Triggern ausgesetzt ist.
Das wäre für ihn ...
Er sagt, das möchte er gerne.
Klar ist: Das Rückfallrisiko
des Pädosexuellen ist hoch.
Etwas ganz Typisches, was er sagt:
"Oh, dein T-Shirt
steckt nicht mehr in der Hose,
ich mach es dir rasch rein."
Das ist
seine typische Vorgehensweise.
Er hat es auch schon
mit leichter Gewalt versucht,
aber dann gemerkt,
dass das nicht sein Ding ist.
Das zeigt, wie er tickt.
Er probiert das ganze Spektrum aus,
um dazu zu kommen, was er will.
Es ist fraglich.
Was sind Erkenntnisse
aus den ganzen Jahren?
Seit über zehn Jahren
wird der Mann in verschiedenen
Institutionen therapiert.
Trotzdem ist vieles unklar.
"Seit ca. ein bis zwei Jahren
nehme er Androcur und Paroxetin."
"Das helfe ihm, mehr zu verstehen
und gebe ihm Sicherheit."
Das hilft ihm, mehr zu verstehen?
Ja, über ... I don't know.
Man weiss ja gar nichts
über seine Sexualität.
Ja, eben - black box.
- Das ist nicht gut.
Nein.
Das Böse ist hier keine Kategorie.
Taten sollen vielmehr durch Umstände
und Persönlichkeitsmerkmale
schlüssig erklärt werden.
Urbaniok spricht
vom Deliktmechanismus,
den es zu verstehen gelte.
In diesem Fall: Wieso hat der Täter
wieder ein Kind missbraucht?
Er war in einem recht engen Setting
eingebunden.
In diesem engen Setting schaffte er
es, einen Rückfall zu haben.
Das ist eigentlich
das Spezielle am Fall.
Ich merke,
ich habe einen grossen inneren -
wenn ich das so reflektiere -
Widerstand, das zu finalisieren.
Im Sinne von: Das ist es.
Vielleicht muss man eher sagen:
Es gibt offene Fragen.
Fazit: ein Scherbenhaufen
mit vielen Fragezeichen.
Ich muss der Fairness halber sagen,
dass in der Supervision
oft schwierige
oder problematische Fälle kommen.
Deswegen
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher,
dass man etwas sieht,
das nicht richtig ist.
Es ist auch richtig,
dass sich in den letzten zehn Jahren
viel verbessert hat.
Aber es ist auch richtig,
dass da viel Luft nach oben ist.
Urbaniok mag Kampfsport,
ist Vegetarier
und hat ein Teufels-Tattoo.
Ich fand das einfach tätowier-
ästhetisch ein total gutes Motiv.
* Er stöhnt bei jedem Schlag. *
Es ist keine tiefere Message
oder Zugehörigkeit
zu einer obskuren Organisation.
Bestimmt gibt es
eine gewisse Anlehnung -
ich bin ein grosser Faust-Fan
und finde die Figur
des Mephistopheles interessant.
Aber darin
ist viel weniger gedankliche Arbeit,
als man vermuten könnte.
Er hat als Student
angefangen zu boxen.
Ihm gefällt es,
physisch und psychisch
total beansprucht zu werden.
Auch die Auseinandersetzung mag er.
Und das Ausloten
der eigenen Belastungsgrenze.
Was müsste passieren, damit Sie im
richtigen Leben jemanden schlagen?
Dass ich angegriffen werde.
Ist das schon mal passiert?
- Ja.
Und dann?
- Hab ich mich gewehrt.
Bin ich nicht
unter die Räder gekommen.
Und wie ging's dann dem anderen?
Ja ...
Er war zumindest abgeschreckt,
würde ich sagen.
Das war dann beendet.
Aber ohne, dass er schwerere Schäden
davongetragen hätte.
Wie passierte das dann?
Was war der Kontext?
Ein Klassiker.
Streit um einen Parkplatz.
* Der Journalist lacht. *
Aber ich war, muss ich sagen,
völlig im Recht.
Ich bin einfach eingeparkt.
Der hatte wohl das Gefühl ...
... das sei sein Parkplatz.
Er fühlte sich total provoziert
und fing sofort an,
körperlich tätig zu werden.
Welche Musik
hören Sie denn eigentlich?
Tote Hosen.
Haben Sie ein Lieblingslied?
Ich habe einige Sportlieder.
Tote Hosen "Helden und Diebe"
ist super,
weil es genau 6 Min. dauert
und mir bei der Bewegung hilft.
Es gibt auch andere Lieder,
die so sind.
* Harte Rockmusik: "Helden und Diebe"
von Die Toten Hosen *
# ... angeklagt wegen Hochverrats.
# An uns selbst
und der Vergangenheit.
# Und dem, was wir mal waren.
# Oh-oh. Oh-oh.
Urbaniok mag auch die intellektuelle
Auseinandersetzung.
Er mischt sich gerne ein,
sucht wenn nötig die Konfrontation
und ist ein zäher Gegner.
Immer mit einem grossen Ziel:
die Schwächeren vor den Übergriffen
von Stärkeren schützen.
Sich nicht einzumischen
heisst manchmal,
dass man Leiden,
Ausbeutung, Misshandlung und Morde
in Kauf nimmt.
Das kann
keine durchgängige Position sein.
Das ist als ob man
in der S-Bahn sehen würde,
dass jemand zusammengeschlagen
oder angepöbelt wird,
und sich nicht einmischt,
weil es einen ja nicht betrifft.
Es ist immer die Frage,
was man dann unternimmt,
aber es zu ignorieren,
nur weil es einen nicht betrifft,
halte ich für eine moralisch
nicht zu rechtfertigende Position.
Viele, die er begutachtet
oder therapiert hat, schätzten ihn,
sagt er, seien ihm gar dankbar.
Aber er erhält
auch Briefe wie diesen:
"So was sollte man in
ein Archipel Gulag versenken dürfen
und es auch tun."
"Adolf Hitler
hätte so etwas im Zweiten Weltkrieg
in Auschwitz vergast und in den Ofen
geschoben und angefeuert."
Ein anderer schrieb ihm:
"Wissen Sie, was passiert,
wenn ein Hochgeschwindigkeits-
projektil mit Hohlspitz
gefüllt mit Quecksilber auf mensch-
liches Gewebe und Knochen trifft?"
"Welcher Arzt wüsste das nicht?"
Für viele Opfer
ist Urbaniok dagegen ein Held.
So auch für diese Frau,
die jahrelang in Todesangst lebte.
Sie musste eine neue Identität
annehmen und umziehen,
um ihrem Stalker zu entkommen.
(Verzerrte Stimme)
Die Polizei sagte immer wieder:
"Solange er Ihnen nichts macht,
können wir nichts machen."
Das machte mich ohnmächtig:
das Wissen,
es einfach ertragen zu müssen.
Ich kann es nicht
aus eigener Kraft verändern,
muss abwarten,
was von seiner Seite kommt.
Welche Rolle spielte Frank Urbaniok
in Ihrem Fall?
Für mich genau im richtigen Moment,
als ich nach langer Zeit
nicht mehr wusste, wie weitermachen,
wie aus dem Ganzen rauskommen,
trat er in mein Leben.
Er hat mir als Erster
die Hand geboten und mich gefragt:
"Wer hilft Ihnen überhaupt?"
Dadurch, dass Herr Urbaniok selbst
auch schon vielfach bedroht wurde
fand ich in ihm endlich jemanden,
den ich ernst nehmen konnte.
Wenn er mir Dinge sagte, war das
für mich nicht salopp dahingesagt.
Endlich hatte ich jemanden, der mich
verstand und der mir wirklich half.
Zeilen eines Missbrauchsopfers,
das über Urbaniok schreibt:
Auch ihnen hat er geholfen:
einer Mutter und ihrer Tochter,
die vergewaltigt wurde.
Man hat ja
diesen unglaublichen Mutterinstinkt,
der einem vorschreibt,
die Kinder zu beschützen.
Und wenn einem
die Möglichkeit genommen wird,
seine Kinder zu beschützen,
steht man vor einer Situation,
in der man nicht weiss,
wie man sich verhalten soll
und was man machen kann,
um seinem Kind zu helfen.
Ich wusste nicht,
was ich machen soll oder kann.
Man fühlt sich einfach ...
... verloren.
Wenn man Opfern nahe ist, teilt man
immer etwas von der Ohnmacht.
Das ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl.
Deshalb setzen im Umfeld nicht
selten schnell Gegenbewegungen ein.
In dem Sinne:
"Jetzt muss mal gut sein."
"Jetzt ist das doch schon so lange
vorbei, vergiss es doch einfach."
Weil es unbequem wird.
Und da beginnt es oft,
dass Opfer einsam werden,
zu wenig Unterstützung haben
oder auf ihr eigenes Schicksal
zurückgeworfen sind.
Da glaube ich,
sind wir alle verpflichtet,
den Betroffenen gegenüber
unterstützender zu sein.
* Nachdenkliche,
elektronische Klänge *
Zurück in Urbanioks Heimat,
wo er als Einzelkind in einfachen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen ist.
Ich würde meine Kindheit
und Jugendzeit
als schöne Zeit bezeichnen.
Man hat wohl sowieso die Tendenz,
das in einem ...
... glücklichen Licht zu sehen.
Natürlich gibt es immer Probleme,
Dinge, die nicht gut sind,
und schlechte Zeiten.
Aber so insgesamt war es für mich
eine ... wirklich schöne Kindheit.
Gilt das für Ihr ganzes Leben?
Ich würde sagen:
in der Gesamtbilanz ja.
Das ist der Weg
direkt zu mir nach Hause.
Also das ist der Schulweg.
Das ist das Haus,
in dem ich den Grossteil
meiner Kindheit verbrachte.
Ahnfeldstrasse 69.
Er wurde 1962
als Sohn eines Baggerführers geboren.
Die Mutter, eine Apothekenhelferin,
blieb zu Hause,
bis der Sohn zehn war.
Dieses Fenster da oben.
Das dritte von unten.
Das war das Wohnzimmer.
Ich habe mich von meinen Eltern
generell und meinem Vater
immer sehr unterstützt
und gestützt gefühlt.
Sie haben vieles richtig gemacht.
Z.B. habe ich in Erinnerung,
dass Leistung
immer mit Freude verbunden war.
Mit meinem Vater
habe ich Wettläufe im Wald gemacht,
er hat mit mir Schach gespielt
oder kam abends von der Arbeit
und ich konnte etwas vorlesen.
Ich kenne es nicht, dass es etwas
Kritisches oder Negatives hatte.
Es war immer: Etwas machen
ist mit Spass und Lust verbunden.
Er nahm die Dinge immer so,
wie sie sind.
Mit einer Gelassenheit
und grundsätzlichen Zufriedenheit
gegenüber dem Leben.
Haben Sie das auch?
Nein, die Zufriedenheit
ist überhaupt keine Stärke von mir.
Ich bin dann schnell dabei:
Was kann man noch anders,
besser machen, weiterentwickeln?
Das ist bei mir ...
Wenn ich Dinge mache,
ist das vielleicht kurzfristig,
aber ich denke
dann schon drüber nach,
was man noch machen,
wie es weitergehen könnte.
Diese ...
- ... innere Bewegung?
Ja. Ja, ja.
So war er schon als Jugendlicher:
ein rastloser Geist.
Er erinnert sich an einen Lehrer,
der ihm mit 16 sagte:
"Frank, Ihnen fehlt die Demut."
Urbaniok fiel durch über-
durchschnittliche Intelligenz auf,
war aber auch unbequem
und streitlustig.
Von Schüler- wie auch Lehrerseite
gab es Personen,
die das irgendwie gut fanden ...
... und Personen, auch Lehrer,
die das ...
Man merkte ...
Die hatten ein Problem damit.
Und das zog sich durch Ihr Leben?
Dieses Muster kenne ich.
Nach meiner Wahrnehmung geht es,
v.a. im beruflichen Kontext,
von Männern aus.
Ohne dass ich das Gefühl habe,
ich provoziere etwas
oder habe einen Konflikt.
Personen fühlen sich durch Dinge,
die ich sage oder mache, provoziert
oder herausgefordert,
ohne dass es mein Ziel ist.
Urbaniok sieht sich
als Querdenker und Macher,
der gerne den Takt vorgibt
und Reaktionen provoziert.
Seine Kritiker
nehmen ihn dagegen als eitel wahr,
als einen, der sich anderen überlegen
fühlt und darum zum Alleingang neigt.
Marc Graf ist ebenfalls Professor
für forensische Psychiatrie.
Er ist Urbaniok
freundschaftlich verbunden,
aber auch immer wieder irritiert.
Als er z.B. Standards publizierte.
Da sagte ich: "Frank, du kannst
nicht allein Standards publizieren."
"Standards
werden im Konsens entwickelt."
"Z.B. von einer Fachgesellschaft."
Ich hätte es mir anders gewünscht.
Dass man einen Vorschlag mal
in eine Fachgesellschaft einbringt,
an wissenschaftlichen Fachtagungen,
die es weltweit gibt.
Da erlebte man Frank selten,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Die International Association for
the Treatment of Sexual Offenders
trägt alle zwei Jahre
hervorragende Fachtagungen aus.
Da ist er halt abwesend.
Er propagiert solche Dinge dann
über "Tages-Anzeiger" oder "NZZ".
Aus meiner subjektiven Perspektive
glaube ich,
dass das der falsche Weg ist.
Mein Weg ist eher ein anderer,
eher das Praktische, das Machen.
Und dann darüber versuchen,
die Praxis zu beeinflussen,
wenn etwas funktioniert.
Als das in Sitzungen über Papiere
und entsprechende breite
Abstimmungen und Verbände zu machen.
Das stimmt.
Können Sie nachvollziehen, dass
das als Arroganz wahrgenommen wird?
Ich kann nachvollziehen,
dass es so wahrgenommen wird.
Ich hoffe, dass diejenigen, die mich
besser kennen, das besser wissen.
Dass es nicht Überheblichkeit oder
Geringschätzung von Menschen ist,
die sich in Verbänden
als Funktionäre einsetzen.
Aber es ist nicht mein primärer Weg.
Einen speziellen Weg
wählte Urbaniok auch,
um sich nach
seiner krankheitsbedingten Auszeit
in der Öffentlichkeit zurückzumelden:
ein grosses Interview
in der "Aargauer Zeitung".
Drei Tage später sollte
der Vierfachmord von Rupperswil
vor dem Aargauer Obergericht
verhandelt werden.
Die zentralen Fragen waren:
Ist Thomas N. therapierbar?
Oder ist er ein Fall
für die lebenslängliche Verwahrung?
Am 21. Dezember 2015
brannte es in Rupperswil.
Schnell wurde klar,
dass die vier Toten,
eine Frau und drei Jugendliche,
die sich im Haus befanden,
ermordet worden waren.
146 Tage wurde ermittelt,
bis die Verhaftung des mutmasslichen
Täters vermeldet werden konnte.
Beim Täter handelt es sich
um einen 33-jährigen Schweizer.
Er ist in Rupperswil wohnhaft.
Er ist ledig, nicht vorbestraft
und nach eigenen Angaben Student.
Die Tat schockierte:
Thomas N. verschaffte sich
mit einer List Zugang zum Haus.
Er bedrohte die vier Anwesenden,
fesselte sie, erpresste Geld,
missbrauchte
den jüngsten Sohn sexuell,
schnitt allen die Kehle durch
und legte einen Brand.
Das Mordwerkzeug für weitere Taten
hatte er bereits gepackt.
Was für ein Mensch
ist zu so etwas fähig?
Diese Frage sollten
zwei forensische Gutachter klären.
Beide diagnostizierten
eine Pädophilie,
einer zudem eine narzisstische,
der andere eine zwanghafte
Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Wieso N. gemordet hatte,
blieb aber offen.
Vor Gericht gehe es nicht nur
um Diagnosen, sagte Urbaniok,
ein Gutachten
müsse auch das Delikt erklären.
Dann kam das grosse Aber.
Ich habe kritisiert: Wenn man
das Delikt nicht erklären kann -
und so war es damals:
Man konnte mit den Gutachten
das Delikt nicht erklären -
dann kann man auch
nichts zur Therapiefähigkeit sagen.
Denn wenn man nicht weiss,
warum jemand eine Tat beging,
weiss man auch nicht, was sich
durch eine Therapie ändern müsste,
damit das Risiko sinkt.
Diese Position ist in seinem
Fachgebiet eine Minderheitsmeinung.
Es gab Applaus,
aber auch harsche Kritik, etwa:
Ich war pro Tag
durchschnittlich 6 Std. am Telefon,
um die Wogen zu glätten.
Damit Dinge, die wir in
Fachgesellschaften und Publikationen
aufgegleist hatten, nicht
extreme Gegenreaktionen auslösen,
die unserem Fachgebiet
insgesamt wieder schaden.
Wenn man drei Tage vor Prozessbeginn
quasi
die Gerichtsgutachter angreift,
klingt das natürlich laut,
führt zu gewaltigen Reibungen.
Ich denke,
das ist grundsätzlich dem Anliegen
eines fairen, ordnungsgemässen,
ruhigen Prozess nicht sehr dienlich.
Wollten wir Prognosen machen
aufgrund des bisherigen Verhaltens,
würden wir sagen: Es scheint,
das Ziel war, Einfluss zu nehmen.
Ich habe überhaupt nichts
gegen Herrn Urbaniok.
Ich sage nur: Das war ein Verhalten,
das ich ehrlich nicht verstehe.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
So ruiniert man seinen Ruf.
Hat Sie die Welle von harschen
Gegenreaktionen erstaunt?
Nein, erstaunt nicht.
Das ...
Nein, es wäre gelogen zu sagen,
es habe mich erstaunt.
Es hat mich vielleicht
dann doch ein wenig erstaunt,
dass kein Einziger
auf meine Argumentation einging.
Die Welle war im Spektrum
von Empörung, Befindlichkeiten,
Unerhörtheiten,
die ich begangen habe.
Und es stimmt schon:
Ich reagiere allergisch,
wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass es
darum geht, Meinungen zu verbieten,
dass man seine Meinung
nicht äussern darf.
Das überzeugt mich
als Argument nicht.
Da sage ich: Wir leben
in einer Demokratie, der Schweiz,
wir leben nicht in Nordkorea.
Weltweit sind Demokratien
auf dem Rückzug. Punkt.
So schreibt Urbaniok Gutachten,
Artikel und ganze Bücher.
Er diktiert druckreif.
Unbeeindruckt vom steifen Gegenwind
im Fall Rupperswil
bastelt er an der nächsten Bombe:
Ausländerkriminalität
sei ein viel grösseres Problem
als von Politik und Medien
dargestellt.
Aber es werde aus falsch verstandener
politischer Korrektheit tabuisiert.
Die Argumente Komma
durch die die Zahlen
relativiert werden sollen Komma
sind nicht annähernd geeignet Komma
die z.T. massiv ...
... bestehenden Überrepräsentationen
ausländischer Straftäter
zu erklären Punkt.
Dieses Tabu
biete Angriffsflächen für Populisten
und sei gefährlich
für unsere Demokratie.
... Bindestrich in den Fällen
Komma ...
Jerome Endrass ist Urbanioks
langjähriger Stellvertreter.
Dass sich Urbaniok immer wieder
mit solchen Themen zu Wort meldet,
überrascht ihn nicht.
Provokation
ist schon einer seiner Aspekte.
Er ist gern
etwas das Enfant terrible,
auch wenn er das wiederum
von sich weisen würde.
Aber wer Frank kennt
und seine Selbstreflexion kennt,
kann zu keinem anderen Schluss
kommen,
als dass er immer wieder Spass
daran hat, zu provozieren.
Zurück in Düsseldorf,
wo Urbaniok im Hotel
an einem Buch über den Aufstieg
populistischer Bewegungen schreibt.
Der Mensch sei grundsätzlich
empfänglich für einfache Botschaften,
so sein Fazit,
das er aus der Evolution herleitet.
Seit es ihm besser geht,
sind Hunderte Seiten entstanden.
Zeit, die er auch
mit seiner Familie oder Freunden
hätte verbringen können.
Gab es Momente des Bedauerns
im Nachhinein?
Dass Sie dachten: "Ich habe
viel verpasst, war zu oft weg."
Nein, weil das wäre ...
... fast ein bisschen ...
... ein unehrliches Bedauern.
Denn es ist ganz klar:
Es war eine Entscheidung
mit Vor- und Nachteilen.
Es ist eine Ausrichtung im Leben.
Man sagt relativ oft:
Wenn ich noch mal zurückkönnte,
würde ich es anders machen.
Aber wenn ich ehrlich bin, würde ich
es vermutlich genauso machen.
Denn die Gründe
aus der Vergangenheit
wären immer noch meine Gründe dafür,
das Leben so zu strukturieren.
Diese Gründe lassen sich
auf einen einfachen Nenner bringen:
Er mischt sich gerne ein
und gestaltet mit.
Die jüngsten Untersuchungen
verliefen allesamt positiv.
Keine Spur mehr vom Krebs.
Aber als geheilt gilt er erst,
wenn er rund zehn Jahre lang
keinen Rückfall hat.
Bis dahin ist es noch ein langer Weg,
der auch abrupt enden kann.
Ich gehe davon aus -
und das war meine Erfahrung in
dieser z.T. sehr schwierigen Zeit -,
dass für mich dann
je nachdem wie etwas verläuft,
die Wahl,
das Leben selbst zu beenden,
eine wichtige Option sein kann.
Damit haben Sie sich
auseinandergesetzt? - Ja.
* Ruhige elektronische Klänge *
Ach, jetzt kommst du zum Beinzeug.
- Ja, die anderen sind besetzt.
Das machst du absichtlich.
- Wieso absichtlich?
Ich kenn dich ja.
Ich hasse dieses Beinzeug.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
* Er lacht. *
Urbaniok hat
zwei inzwischen erwachsene Söhne,
die seine Frau
mit in die Beziehung brachte
und aufzog,
während er v.a. arbeitete.
Yannic ist 20 und teilt
die Sportbegeisterung seines Vaters.
Du musst weiter hoch!
- Sei still.
Sei still, sonst habe ich
schwere Beine beim Boxen.
Kann mich nicht mehr bewegen.
- Musst du auch nicht.
Ja, klar.
Da grinst er.
Parat?
- Okay.
Durch seine Erkrankung
hat sich die Bedeutung
von Arbeit und Leistung relativiert
in Urbanioks Leben.
Seine Prioritäten
haben sich verschoben.
Der Beruf ist heute
ein wichtiger Nebenaspekt,
die Familie und einige wenige Freunde
die Hauptsache.
Fertig, fertig!
Super. Super, super. Du Tier!
Danke, Frank. Ne, brauch ich nicht.
Beim Arm hast du mich besiegt,
aber beim Bein ich dich.
Haben Sie Angst vor dem Tod?
Hm ...
Ja, sicher, ich habe
auch Angst vor dem Tod, aber ...
Wie das viele andere sagen,
auch Betroffene:
Angst noch mehr vor dem Sterben,
vor dem, wie das dann ist.
Natürlich ist der Tod
viel mehr in mein Leben gerückt.
In der Vergangenheit,
den letzten zwei Jahren,
aber auch in der Zukunft -
er ist viel präsenter als vorher.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen ...
Er gehört leider zum Leben dazu.
Machst du nie Schultern?
- Doch.
Also hier ist ja eigentlich Nacken.
Ja, aber halt seitlich oder Arnold.
So, jetzt my father.